[Applauso]
[Musica]
che cosa accadrebbe se domattina vi
svegliaste in un mondo senza musica vi
perdereste sicuramente qualcosa di bello
qualcosa che vi piace ma sarebbe
semplicemente rinunciare a qualcosa che
vi piace come mangiare la pizza il
sabato sera o andres incontro ad un
cambio molto più profondo
la musica ovunque la ritroviamo in tutte
le culture in ogni angolo del mondo
perché quello che ci permette di
connettere gli uni con gli altri
è un collante relazionale basti pensare
a quello che succede normalmente nei nei
concerti e della colonna sonora delle
nostre giornate dei nostri eventi la
musica sembra proprio qualcosa che ci
portiamo dietro da sempre l'oggetto un
po strano che vedete alle mie spalle è
un reperto archeologico e più
precisamente si tratta di un osso e
l'osso di un orso delle caverne
risalente a circa 55 mila anni fa
cosa c'entra c'entra perché alcuni
studiosi si sono concentrati su questo
osso proprio su quei fori e hanno
provato a ricostruirlo formulando un
ipotesi che per noi oggi è molto più
attraente infatti potrebbe trattarsi
dello strumento musicale più antico
della storia quello che poi è stato
soprannominato il flauto di neanderthal
accade spesso che quello che ritroviamo
fin dai primi passi della nostra
evoluzione come esseri umani in realtà
lo troviamo anche nei primi passi della
nostra evoluzione come singoli individui
cioè della nostra vita
e sono proprio degli studi di
neuroscienze ad indicarci che noi
nasciamo già come esseri musicali
infatti il nostro cervello quando siamo
neonati prime ore di vita riesce a
rispondere specificatamente alla musica
alla struttura musicale alla melodia al
ritmo alle differenti sfumature emotive
della musica in effetti la presenza
della musica nella nostra vita sembra
avere a che fare proprio con nostro
cervello e in particolare con dei
cambiamenti che avvengono nei suoi
circuiti più antichi a livello evolutivo
cioè quelli più profondi anche a livello
anatomico
era un ruolo chiave qui è una sostanza
che è cruciale per la regolazione del
nostro comportamento tutti i giorni
questa sostanza è la dopamina la
dopamina un neurotrasmettitore che noi
di solito liberiamo proprio nelle aree
più antiche e profonde del nostro
cervello in risposta a stimoli come il
cibo o il sesso sono stimoli che ci
attraggono che ci danno piacere che ci
motivano che ci danno ricompensa e che
sono anche in qualche modo legati alla
nostra sopravvivenza
quello che però abbiamo recentemente
scoperto e che in realtà la dopamina
viene liberata anche in risposta alla
musica allora vediamo un po quanti di
voi almeno una volta nella vita
ascoltando una canzone un brano musicale
hanno provato questa sensazione qui a
occhio direi un 90 per cento abbondante
questi sono brividi pelle d'oca sono
risposte del nostro corpo fisiologiche o
psico fisiologiche che possiamo
associare al piacere intenso in una
parte delle mie ricerche io mi sono
focalizzata proprio su questo tipo di
fenomeni abbordando lì però in un modo
un po particolare
infatti con dai colleghi di barcellona
di montreal siamo andati ad attivare o
disattivare direttamente nel cervello
quelli che pensavamo potessero essere i
meccanismi alla base di questi fenomeni
e in particolare proprio la liberazione
di dopamina
lo abbiamo fatto grazie ad uno studio
farmacologico che ci ha permesso di
andare ad aumentare o diminuire
temporaneamente quindi non vi
preoccupate e la liberazione di dopamina
nel cervello delle persone e l'abbiamo
fatto mentre le persone mentre i nostri
partecipanti ascoltavano musica la
musica poteva essere la loro musica
preferita o della musica pop rock che
avevamo scelto noi è quella che
normalmente passa in radio
quello che abbiamo trovato è che quando
la dopamina aumentava rispetto a quando
diminuiva aumentavano anche le loro
risposte di piacere cioè partecipanti ci
dicevano di amare di più un certo brano
musicale e avevano anche più risposte
fisiologiche associate i brividi da
pelle d'oca
non solo quando aumentava la dopamina
aumentavano anche quelle risposte che
noi chiamiamo motivazionali in questo
caso i partecipanti erano disposti a
pagare di più per ottenere il brano che
stavano ascoltando c'erano risposte a
dare dei soldi per avere quel brano
quella musica nella loro vita
quindi il piacere la motivazione legati
alla liberazione di dopamina sono
fondamentali quando cerchiamo di capire
il ruolo della musica nella nostra vita
o quantomeno perché è nella nostra vita
rimane però aperto una domanda
fondamentale cioè tutto questo piacere
così avvolgente così intenso che che
cambia le nostre giornate in positivo è
fine a se stesso cioè quale veramente il
ruolo della musica nella nostra vita per
provare a rispondere vi propongo di
continuare insieme un viaggio nelle
attivazioni cerebrali e vi chiedo per
quanto possibile di provare immaginare
di essere qui da soli mettervi le vostre
cuffie le vostre cuffie auricolari e
cominciare ad ascoltare una delle vostre
canzoni preferite quello che accadrà è
che il vostro cervello comincerà ad
accendersi creando una vera e propria
costellazione di attivazioni che
riguardano aree che si attivano e che
regolano le nostre emozioni il nostro
comportamento ma anche altre aree che
sono implicate nella percezione nel
movimento nel linguaggio nella memoria
la musica crea una vera e propria
sinfonia neurale nel nostro cervello lo
attiva lo modulo interamente e così
facendo è capace di modularne l'anatomia
e la funzionalita allora adesso possiamo
fare un passaggio fondamentale visto che
la maggior parte di questi substrati
neurali la maggior parte di queste aree
che la musica attiva in realtà sono aree
che noi attiviamo tutti i giorni per
compiere tantissime altre attività
sentire e leggere parlare e camminare
allora possiamo cominciare a pensare di
usare la musica per stimolare queste
altre regioni e quindi queste altre
funzioni queste altre funzioni
quotidiane e quello che ad oggi hanno
fatto moltissimi studi di psicologia di
neuroscienze ad esempio gli studi che si
sono interessati alla capacità della
musica di stimolare delle aree
implicate nel movimento e come questa
possa essere utilizzata in caso di
deficit di movimento come nella malattia
di parkinson o ancora gli studi che si
sono focalizzati sul rapporto
strettissimo che c'è tra la musica il
linguaggio la musica un vero e proprio
linguaggio universale e possiamo
utilizzare questo rapporto
ad esempio per migliorare le capacità di
lettura in bambini dislessici di ricerca
se n'è fatta tanta e come spesso accade
nella ricerca scientifica tanta ne
rimane da fare e da supportare
io oggi vorrei parlarvi di una fetta di
questa ricerca è qualcosa che mi
interessa particolarmente ma che in
realtà ci tocca tutti nel profondo
perché si tratta del rapporto che esiste
tra la musica e la nostra memoria
prima però lasciate che si attivi un po
nel vostro cervello quella sinfonia
neurale grazie alle note che che vi farà
andrea
[Musica]
bene
la musica ha un fortissimo
[Applauso]
ovviamente questa presentazione non
avrebbe lo stesso valore senza tutto
questo so che è un valore aggiunto
quindi la musica ha un fortissimo potere
evocativo cioè un brano musicale al
potere letterale di farci viaggiare nel
tempo perché grazie di un brano musicale
noi possiamo recuperare sensazioni
esperienze persone emozioni che
associamo quel brano
magari è quello che vi è successo adesso
con questa versione di bohemian rhapsody
a giudicare dall applauso dire di sì
perché sicuramente via suonata familiare
altri non riconosciuta il fan fin da
subito dalle prime note e altri ci hanno
messo un po di più insieme al
riconoscimento è arrivato il ricordo
delle parole associate per alcuni ed
altri sono andati oltre e sono riusciti
ad associare a questo brano dei ricordi
della propria vita
noi questo potere evocativo della musica
l'abbiamo preso e l'abbiamo portato in
laboratorio con il fine di capire quali
fossero i meccanismi alla base e capire
quindi un po di più che cosa ci fosse
dietro abbiamo condotto vari studi su
persone giovani su persone anziane in
cui chiedevamo di memorizzare delle
informazioni con o senza musica e nel
frattempo però monitoravamo anche la
loro attività cerebrale
quello che abbiamo scoperto è che la
musica può veramente aiutarci a
ricordare meglio le informazioni e nel
farlo cioè mentre aiuta i nostri
processi di memoria modula il nostro
cervello andando a modulare quelle aree
che si sappiamo essere importanti per
memorizzare mantenere recuperare un
informazione ma anche aree che sono
implicate nella regolazione delle nostre
emozioni e quindi nel nostro piacere
eccole che le ritroviamo le nostre
risposte di piacere qui non sono fini a
se stesse diventano rilevanti diventano
fondamentali perché quello che abbiamo
scoperto è che più siamo in grado di
attivare le nostre risposte di piacere
di ricompensa di motivazione in risposta
alla musica più brividi abbiamo più
queste risposte potranno attivare delle
regioni che sono importanti nella
formazione dei nostri ricordi e quindi
maggiori saranno i benefici
la musica sulla nostra memoria questo
ovviamente ha delle implicazioni
importantissima e soprattutto se
pensiamo ai casi di deficit di memoria
soprattutto se pensiamo alla nostra
società che va incontro ad un incremento
dell invecchiamento sia normale sia
patologico durante le mie ricerche ho
avuto l'opportunità grandissima di
vedere dei back dei pazienti alzheimer
che erano completamente spenti dalla
malattia essere in grado di riconoscere
un brano del loro passato e anche solo
per un secondo uscire da quella patia la
musica attraverso le emozioni in queste
persone riesce a far riaffiorare dei
ricordi autobiografici cioè dei ricordi
della loro vita che proprio a causa
della malattia sembravano persi fino
all'istante prima e in alcuni casi
riesce anche a facilitare
l'apprendimento di nuove informazioni
questo tipo di ricerche ci fa capire un
po di più come funzioniamo come funziona
il nostro cervello che il nostro organo
più complesso e forse più affascinante e
io credo che ci insegnino anche qualcosa
in questo caso ci insegnano che le
nostre risposte emozionali emotive
quelle di piacere quelle che
consideriamo più istintive arcaiche
basse irrazionali in realtà le possiamo
prendere e le possiamo utilizzare per
andare a modulare migliorare stimolare
delle funzioni cognitive che invece
consideriamo alte complesse come
l'apprendimento la memoria
tutti gli studi di neuroscienze musica
vanno nella stessa direzione nel
sottolineare l'importanza della musica
nella nostra vita e nella nostra vita
significa nella nostra società non solo
nelle nostre case nelle nostre cuffie ma
anche in ambito educativo quando
muoviamo i primi passi nella società e
in ambito clinico
quando invece abbiamo delle difficoltà
sul nostro percorso
la musica uno strumento potente ma
questa potenza non è invasiva ea basso
costo e non solo può ma deve essere
accessibile a tutti quindi riempiamo la
nostra vita di musica diamo la
possibilità al nostro cervello di
cambiare e trasformarsi nel profondo e
di farlo per tutto l'art
della nostra esistenza diamogli la
possibilità di un cambiamento che è
fondamentale per il nostro funzionamento
cognitivo
ascoltiamo musica facciamo musica non ci
perdiamo neanche un secondo di quel
piacere di quei brividi che ci può dare
liberiamo tutta la dopamina possibile
attenzione però scegliamo la bene la
musica che ascoltiamo oggi perché
potrebbe essere proprio quella a
riattivarsi domani
grazie
[Applauso]